Andre asks Gary I'm interested in your
thoughts about marketing opportunities
on Yik yak Andre so this is a great
question back to the attention graph
that I just told in here that we need to
drill on the biggest reason I'm talking
about yet yak so much is it does have
the overwhelming attention at scale of
this kind of 18 to 22 year old demo
that's on college campuses the truth is
I'm not really prepared to answer this
question that's why I took it the truth
is I haven't put in enough work on Yik
yak it's here right it's here but look
look what do you kick is right I know
dear rock you're doing a lot of like I'm
sorry but this is important this is
another insight some of the stuff I do
it's why I grab so many people's phones
right
look what do you kick is as you can see
socials really jamming here right but
you get in this little folder it says
social and it's not even on the first
one it's here so clearly are you
laughing cuz you're not getting a good
zoom oh it's hiding that's right the
rocket is hiding and so so even though
I'm talking a big game about my belief
in the attack my actions aren't
following my words right now I'm doing a
bad job of not being the best expert at
yet yak I haven't spent a lot of time in
there obviously the kind of anonymous
commenting you know how do you get away
with like promoting your burger joint or
a pizza shop or Wine Library give to 21
and 22 year old you kick users like what
do you do like do you ask a question
about your own business or do you make a
statement about your own business that's
a little spammy that you know the
problem with the IKEA as a marketing
platform right now is it's like the old
forums back in the day when everybody
was anonymous and 90s and I would go to
like wine spectator's wine bulletin
board and be like Wine Library is an
amazing store in town it you know you
don't know how to do it right right like
I guess in theory you can make a comment
of like I hear that the Johnny burgers
own cook is really hot
hahaha cuz it's me like I guess there's
a way if you're very authentic you can
win that game and there's clearly ways
to market unfortunately the thing I make
fun of so many of you of and so many
people love which is you're not a
practitioner you're reading headlines I
unfortunately this situation and a lack
of a practitioner and you did a little
bit of more my work as you can tell I
have enough
dangerous knowledge of giving you an
example some of the things you can do
but you know the question will become
what will you yak allow brands to do if
anything but clearly let's if you have a
restaurant or hangout in the college
demo right now and you're not
desperately trying to figure out yet
every minute you're making a huge
mistake